ja bei mir ist jetzt norbert röttgen
chef außenpolitiker der
unions-bundestagsfraktion und kandidat
für den cdu-vorsitz herr röttgen
merkwürdige szenen die wir aus den usa
sehen ein nicht ergebnis quasi was sagen
sie dazu was sich gerade in den usa
abspielt
also es ist alles enger geworden als
viele mich eingeschlossen erwartet haben
sieht aber jetzt sehr klar nach einem
ganz knappen sieg von joe biden aus er
braucht noch einen staat dann hat er die
mehrheit aber der kampf wird nun erst
richtig noch mal ausbrechen
donald trump wird sich nicht geschlagen
geben es strikt an seiner legende
er wird versuchen dass das auszählen
gestoppt wird es wird gericht anträge an
die gerichte geben wir werden jetzt noch
tage und wochen eines kampfes erleben
aber ich denke es wird ein knappes
ergebnis geben die nase vorn hat jetzt
joe biden kampf nur ein juristischer
kampf oder auch wie viele andere
befürchten straßenschlachten oder und in
den usa nicht in diese in diese tasten
greifen mit unruhen aber man muss
befürchten kann nicht ausschließen dass
das wovon ich glaube dass es bei tram
sozusagen legendenbildung ist ich bin
nicht besiegt worden sondern betrogen
worden
das könnten schon manche seiner anhänger
wörtlich nehmen und glauben die
demokratie in usa wird bedroht wird
betrogen und könnten zu mitteln greifen
die die außerhalb von demokratische
auseinandersetzung liegen also man muss
ein bisschen sorge haben nicht unruhen
und dergleichen aber das ist ganz
es ist nicht ganz sicher dass es völlig
ohne jede gewalt vonstatten geht wie
groß ist aus ihrer sicht denn der
schaden der im verhältnis deutschland
und usa unter donald trump entstanden
ist ist es alleine trans schuld und was
muss dann jetzt passieren von deutscher
seite aus vor allem also dass das
verhältnis sich so entwickelt hat
das ist glaube ich das ergebnis des
bruchs den donald trump bedeutet das ist
ja ein absoluter bruch mit 70 jahren
amerikanischer nachkriegspolitik wir
ständen nicht hier wo wir stehen ohne
die usa das heißt ohne engagement das
ist nicht amerika
sondern das ist verantwortung für die
demokratie und die freiheit in der welt
das ist der bruch der eingetreten ist
aber wenn sie fragen für die zukunft wir
sind eben nicht mehr im kalten krieg die
usa werden niemals wieder diese rolle
wahrnehmen sie müssen sich um das eigene
land auch der nächste präsident kümmern
zuallererst die zweite priorität ist
china das wird der fokuspunkt auch unter
den in der außenpolitik seien
das heißt für uns ist das eine riesen
chance dass wir dieses transatlantische
verhältnis die partnerschaft mit den usa
neu ausfüllen können sie wird jetzt auch
unter beiden wieder von den usa gewollt
und dann müssen wir etwas bringen und
nicht nur erwartungen äußern was die usa
jetzt wieder tun sollten sondern wir
müssen es ausfüllen mit eigenen
initiativen mit eigenen ressourcen mit
eigener politik und mit eigenem geld
welche rolle kann in deutschland spielen
in dem verhältnis dass du dann haben wir
in china auf der einen seite und die usa
und dann noch dazu russland was muss in
deutschland oder was europa tun
wir haben eine ganz entscheidende rolle
erstens dafür dass in diesem verhältnis
europa entsteht als in außenpolitische
handlungsfähigkeit außenpolitisch
handlungsfähig wir werden keine einheit
der 27 staaten hinbekommen und trotzdem
müssen wir statten zusammenbringen
müssen wir ein europäisches gewicht in
die waagschale werfen
dafür ist deutschland entscheidend eine
gruppe zu bilden die sagt wir gehen
jetzt mal voran und machen europäische
politik ganz entscheidend und dann
glaube ich müssen wir die verhältnisse
zu allen die sie genannt haben neu
definieren wir haben über usa gesprochen
china ist unterschiedlich ping nicht
mehr nur ein großer markt für deutsche
produkte für manche deutsche produkte
sondern die große herausforderung da
können wir jetzt gemeinsamkeiten mit den
usa finden kein feindseliges verhältnis
zu china aber doch eines aus der stärke
heraus und ähnliches gilt für russland
da ist auch eine gemeinsame position aus
stärke heraus geboten und die können wir
jetzt wieder gemeinsam mit den usa
formulieren wir sollten jedenfalls
vorschläge dafür machen und das wollen
die usa führen einen sogenannten
handelskrieg gegen gegen china
und sie verlangen von deutschland den
stopp von nord stream
zu diesen zwei punkten ich bin für eine
position der stärke gegenüber china aber
nicht für eine feindselige haltung in
china ist eine realität eine ganz
bedeutende realität an der man nicht
vorbei kann und wir sollten darum eine
partnerschaft ein verhältnis korrigiere
mich ein verhältnis auf augenhöhe finden
das auch in unserer eigenen stärke seine
grundlage hat vor allen dingen
technologisch und nord team 2 ist ein
ist ein beispiel dafür dass
meinungsverschiedenheiten zwischen usa
und der deutschen regierung bleiben
ich war immer ein gegner dieses
projektes weil es viel schaden stiftet
auch im transatlantischen verhältnis und
auch eine regierung beiden hält von
diesem projekt nichts weil es ja ein
machtpolitisches projekt putins ist und
darum werden streitpunkte bleiben und
die amerikaner hatten auch in der
vergangenheit nicht immer nur unrecht
ihr mitkonkurrent um den cdu-vorsitz
friedrich merz sagt er könnte wenn du
deinen kanzler werden würde und vorher
cdu-chef werden werden würde könnte er
mit donald trump käme ja ganz ganz gut
klar wie kennen sie damit donald trump
klar
vielleicht war die äußerung ja ein
bisschen voreilig von friedrich merz
denn möglicherweise kommt es ja aus
mehreren gründen gar nicht dazu dass er
das ausprobieren kann
ich hätte eben jetzt von meiner seite
nicht unterstellt dass er die
gemeinsamkeiten so findet wenn er sie
selber sieht werde ich ihnen mal bei
gelegenheit fragen worin sie denn
bestehen
es sieht ja jetzt anders aus joe biden
hat die nase vorne aber der ergebnis
liegt noch nicht vor
ich kann nur sagen mit dem gesamten haus
und politischen umfeld von joe biden
dass ich sehr gut kenne aber andere auch
kommen wir hervorragend aus das ist die
basis um gemeinsame politik zu machen
vielen dank herr röttgen mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bate schau dich hier das nächste video
an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren